wearing purple eyeliner to distract from
it overall lack of hygiene if there are
any investors out there that would like
to invest in an idea I have for a
product that is a body wash and or
deodorant called shower you know where
to find me by myself on the internet
waiting for you hey guys it is 20 it's
grace it's time to talk back to you
let's start on tumblr fancy trinet a new
person to person to person probably
don't know what a new person in comments
on one of my social media outlets I
praise the crap and all them and welcome
to the it's grace family how do I know
if it's a new person I have no [ __ ]
clue I just guess and a lot of times I
just praise the same people over and
over I don't I am not playing favorites
this is why I couldn't have children
because I would forget which one was my
favorite which one was it and I would
probably give the one that wasn't just
like too much attention and then they
grow up to think that they can do
anything and I'd be like [ __ ] straighten
that one out when I had a chance fancy
TriNet a more like fancy feast [ __ ]
your progress how do you do the flawless
without even trying thing do you mean
how do i do the flawed while trying
really hard thing it's just an eight oh
my how big new person to person to
person born like oh my how big is that
doggie in the window whoa he seems like
it's actually a guy dressed as a dog cuz
bigger than a normal dog whoa you before
my grace thanks for making me feel less
[ __ ] when I should be sleeping okay
night that's why I'm here for to make
people feel let's [ __ ] step touch and
[ __ ] with your hands that is not the
right thing to do permanent state of
flavors nippers new person permits day
to flail more like my cousin for sudden
you broke yes finally ordered Hannah and
graces books can't wait to read them if
you guys don't know on amazon amazon
that sneaky sneaky little temptress has
paired Hannah nice books together for a
price go check it out now let's go over
to Twitter
Butler my muffin new person to person to
person Butler my muffin more like why'd
you name your muffin Butler oh but what
a joy would be to name your Butler
muffin human / my friend thanks grace
Helbig steals children I don't know how
to feel stealing children you don't pay
me to steal children I can't can't they
cannot hold a conversation or their
urine now this is just me describing my
own special skills Shelley max dead new
person to person new person Shelley
maxstep more like Shelley max Ted she
got a big head otherwise you can't ride
motorcycles you can't get a helmet
fitter she just wears a metal lampshade
you before moving different states soon
by myself and I have no family where I'm
going I'm only 18 good advice so I don't
get homesick fix your sentence structure
also don't be afraid to put yourself out
there and be friends with common
interests like other people that don't
care about sentence structure Courtney
hobby new president / snoopers important
ehow be more like Kourtney needs a hobby
my right that girl that knows that
because I was about a room where
something was a poner but we didn't get
to meet sad face I'm sorry maybe in some
other time in the future we'll meet
maybe a DA naru woman in terms of school
bus listen to music in her backyard the
sound times I just wander over down our
Road who those in folder just miss Jen
new person to person to person just miss
Jen more like just miss Jen hifi that
bid this really sweet room aboard I had
24 years old my mother just kicked me
out of the room because I was laughing
too hard this video and it was
distracting her from reading her book so
much for family bonding this was the
comment left on the fart soundboard
challenge ain't know why she kicked
around the room because she probably had
to fart guess what your mom farts all
moms fart moms fart that's a great
t-shirt you 166 mhz newport
person you 166 mhz more like are you a
captcha code how did a captcha code make
a youtube account to of all I can tell
you what I see you gotta go now thank
you so much that's over talking back to
you today I hope you enjoy your time
here I don't know races guidebook com